now that you have this this studio album
coming out how are you feeling
I'm feeling good you know I released my
last album brightest blue my fourth
album during lockdown so that was an
interesting time because I was doing
lots of uh shows from my toilet so that
was interesting
um and um and I didn't go to get to go
on tour I didn't get to see any of my
fans you know it was a strange kind of
time to release music and at the time
you know it was a very personal album to
me and it was one that I I really was
like right this is the one this is my
album and you know I was desperate to
like talk about it and uh and to really
explain where those songs had come from
and then and then you know bam the the
pandemic happened
um so I didn't really get to do that um
so this this next album higher than
Heaven my new album is is really a
reaction to to coming out of the
pandemic and just wanting to kind of
Escape that and I think we were all
myself and the other writers were just
Keen to
put out an album that was full of joy
and
um and escape and yeah that's kind of
what we did so I'm feeling good about it
I'm excited for it to come out and
excited for people to hear it and
excited to go on tour with it because
God knows it's been a long time
yeah I can only imagine
um you know you are creating new music
during a lockdown uh you had a baby how
much did all of that really influence
you as an artist when creating music for
this album
well I think it did the opposite to what
you'd expect I think that maybe there's
a slight delay in my reaction to to the
to the pandemic and to you know becoming
a mom obviously it's just
it's such a profound and ginormous
change in your life
that it's impossible for that to not
perfect you as a writer you know your
brain is suddenly a universe instead of
like a I don't know a planet and so you
you've suddenly got all these new
thoughts all these new feelings and so
yeah naturally you're just gonna start
your writing is just going to start
heading in different directions
um but for this album I I just wasn't
ready to do that you know whether I was
kind of stuck in the surrealness of
pregnancy or like the pandemic I think
we were all experiencing a bit of that
you know like just trying to process
experiencing a pandemic and you know
experiencing genuine loss and and and
really really hard times
um it's not something we we were ready
to explore so we're like you know what
let's just write fun things let's just
have fun as writers as people that are
good at making pop records let's just do
that and so it really it really worked
for us you know it made us feel happy we
felt like we'd got to a place where you
know we were playing the music we were
dancing around and we were yeah you know
just just enjoying
being able to be around other people and
know that we could go out dancing and go
out seeing others it just I don't know
it just all kind of was in that moment
and that's not to say that an album
isn't coming where I get really personal
and talk about becoming a mum because
that's a whole that's like 10 albums
worth you know
um so I'll do that at some point yeah
I love that well speaking of songs that
just want to make you dance I love your
song like a savior and those those that
the dancers are so beautiful do you have
dance moves like that
do I have dancers like that yeah
um you know I really love to dance
dancing is really good for you and even
if you're dancing and you're by yourself
it's really good to put some music on
and dance alone like there's nothing
wrong with that and but I I'm not an
actual I guess dancer but I love to move
I love to stretch I love to you know do
I do a lot of yoga um those guys are
just unreal like they're just born to
like to dance
um but um I wish I could dance you know
it would it would make my life a lot
easier when people are like right for
this performance you decided that you
just do this and I'm like uh I just
can't singing for now
um I need to get one of those like
little you know my head mics
um
not sure if that's the right Vibe for me
I love that I know your fans are so
excited that you're collaborating again
with Calvin Harris what is it about you
two that works so well because I know
this is your third collaboration
together yes
yes um I don't know I think we just have
a connection with music maybe we both
grew up loving the same music maybe we
just our personalities just work well
together in the studio but I don't I
don't really question what he does I
um I let him do his thing because he is
so he's so sure of of himself in the
best possible way and of his
of his skill as a producer and why would
anyone question it like you know he's
had
Banger after Banger and and also like
songs you know they're not just like
throwaway dance songs records they're
actual songs you can break down and put
with a guitar and it's still in a really
beautiful record so
I think I think that's the beauty that
he has is that he's a genuinely great
songwriter and he doesn't like fluff you
know everything is just quality and so
yeah I mean I I love working with people
that are just incredible writers I I
feel lucky that as a singer I get to
work with the best writers in the world
and he's one of them you know so we just
have some kind of I don't know thing
it's hard to explain but um clearly like
people just respond well to it and we're
just gonna probably keep doing it
absolutely
um I know is your birthday earlier this
year and you posted this amazing caption
about accepting that it's okay to be
proud of your work so when it comes to
this album on a scale of one to ten how
proud are you
oh for for lots of reasons I'm you know
I'm up there with like a nine or a ten
because wow you know I've had a really
tough year with anxiety
um I've had you know my imposter
syndrome all that's all that stuff
that's women get on the regular has been
at Peak and you know post pandemic
becoming a mum it's all it's all really
just me you know it does make you
question your entire
you know who you are you're like
your beliefs your you know your fears
your
um you know your reaction to things it
can change everything so like anxiety
has been a real honest um and so I'm
really proud that I'm at a place where
I'm releasing my fifth album I'm gonna
go on tour I'm
um you know I'm before I'm I'm
performing every day I'm speaking openly
every day and I I feel I feel I don't
know I just feel I feel proud of myself
and we have to accept those moments you
know for for so many years I I was a
kind of apologetic about my music and
like sorry I'm just gonna sing another
song and and you know I didn't think I
deserved to be where I was and
I didn't put myself up there and I think
that even if you got it like I remember
Rihanna saying interview recently like
if you don't feel it once Sunday you
know you just gotta fake it you know and
you just you just gotta fake it and at
least then I've learned recently you
know about manifesting and about using
the right language for your brain
because
how you describe yourself and the love
you give to yourself
it can really it really stays there it
imprints itself so if you're saying to
yourself every day I'm you know I am I
am I don't know a good presenter I am
I'm a I'm a I'm a good performer or I
write good lyrics or I you know you've
got to sort of write those things down
or at least sort of you know use them as
a mantra because your brain will take no
and and then usually you know you can
you can it's really hard to explain you
know what I mean it's like you you just
sort of have to you just have to use
um like positive language and put
yourself in that mindset
um because it can really make a
difference
did you does Lena Dunham know that that
post was inspired by her words yes I
told her yeah oh yeah we message a bit
and um I just love the way she writes I
think she's brilliant and so um I had to
let her know
well thank you so much congratulations
on this music I love it it's and I can
see like even comments from all your
fans they're like yes we've been waiting
for this so congratulations yeah I think
this one is up listing albums just you
know bringing out that flunk maybe and
um yeah just like enjoy the summer and
dance and
um maybe we just need to escape
things like that so yeah thanks so much
Ellie thank you bye